Wie heißt du? Ich heiße Angela.
Mein Name ist Rosi. Ich heiße Julie.
Ich heiße David. Ich heiße Emilio.
Ich heiße Lui. Ich heiße Arides.
Eckbert Stern. Ich heiße Eleni.
Ich heiße Pauli. Ich heiße Lydia Löffler.
Woher kommst du? Ich komme aus Zürich.
Ich komme aus der Schweiz. Ich komme aus Frankreich.
Ich bin halb Mexikaner und halb Deutscher. Ich bin halb Mexikaner und halb Deutscher.
Ich komme aus München. Ich komme aus Berlin.
Ich auch. Ich komme aus Berlin und äh
bin aber nicht hier geboren worden, sondern ich komme aus Thüringen.
Ich komme aus Berlin. Ich komme aus Köln.
Ich komme aus Deutschland. Wo lebst du?
Ich lebe in Zürich. Momentan lebe ich in Zürich.
Ich lebe in Berlin. Ich wohne in Berlin-Charlottenburg.
Ich leb' hier in Berlin, Charlottenburg. Ich wohne in Berlin.
Ich lebe in Berlin, Berlin-Mitte. Ich lebe in Berlin-Mitte und in Kreuzberg.
Ich lebe in Brandenburg. Ich wohne in Berlin.
Ich lebe in Berlin. Was ist dein Beruf?
Das ist schwierig. Ich äh bin Gastronom.
Ich schneide Filme. Ich gehe noch zur Schule.
Ich geh' zur Schule und mach' zur Zeit Abi. Ich bin Student.
Äh wir sind Schüler. Ich bin ein Lehrer.
Was lehren Sie? Geschichte und Geografie.
Ich hab gerade meine Schule abgeschlossen. Ich studiere.
Ich bin ähm, arbeite in der IT. Was ist dein Hobby?
Ich geh' gerne Fahrrad fahren. Meine Hobbies sind zeichnen,
Fahrrad fahren und schwimmen. Bier trinken.
Ich äh reise gerne und ich lese gerne und ich trinke gerne Kaffee.
Meine Hobbies sind Theater spielen, malen, zeichnen, klettern oder anderen Sport.
Ich spiele gerne Fußball, mach' gern Sport wie klettern,
joggen gehen und lese noch gerne, treff' mich mit Freunden.
Meine Hobbies sind kochen, Musik machen, reisen. Unsere Hobbies, also was wir in der
Freizeit machen: draußen sein,
mit Freunden treffen, tanzen gehen, ja. Oh, oh, das ist schwer. Fahrrad fahren,
äh, schwimmen, lesen. Mein Hobby ist, sich mit Freunden zu treffen
und das Leben zu genießen. Hobbies ähm ich lese gern. Ich schwimme gern.
(Ich) geh' gern ins Kino. Das war ein Video für
Menschen, die gerade anfangen, Deutsch zu lernen. In den nächsten Wochen
werden wir noch viele weitere solche Videos produzieren,
die für A1 und A2 Niveau gedacht sind. Wenn ihr zu diesem Video noch interaktive Übungen
machen wollt, dann werdet ein Patreon von Easy German.
Dann bekommt ihr jede Woche Übungen zu unseren Videos,
lernt das Vokabular, die Ausdrücke und die Grammatik.
Hier könnt ihr Easy German abonnieren. Bis bald.